let's just go have fun and let go a
little
yeah that ain't my kind of fun you know
what's fun for me waking up early
hitting the gym spending time with my
Creator building the life I desire and
more importantly becoming a better
version of myself every damn day so if
your kind of fun is getting shit-faced
over the weekend that's cool but we
don't do that over here we're focused on
God goals and growth
Triple G
mic drop
this one rules I love the way these are
shot honestly well because I can't get
with someone
I'm single because every time I focus on
somebody they show me exactly what I'm
better off alone
who did that has what is her name
like just what is your name that's what
pops off on reels yeah
like if you're ever wondering like
you're on my Instagram account's not
growing like what do I just post [__]
like that yeah yeah it's ridiculous
if you're not if you're not eating to
prevent starvation
then why the [__] are you eating at all
eating for fun you want fun you go
hiking you go swimming yeah if you're
not eating to prevent starvation you're
not ready to [__] eat yeah
it's just such extremes man
also hilarious like
if you're not dating for marriage I
don't know maybe you're dating to find
out if you could get married that's what
I'm saying
no but I think he's saying you shouldn't
even do that if you're not willing to
like you're not willing to marry the
first person yeah I know but that's
[__] dumb yeah
sorry sorry no I mean it kind of is like
you can the like then 80 of the reason
people date is for fun yeah yeah look
it's supposed to be fun
I just think these like
the these things on reels are so funny
because all these people are super young
and they say these really drastic things
and they don't really know who they are
yet yeah you check back with that guy in
like four years and he could be like
uh yeah yeah I'm a club promoter uh
marriage is turns out this [__] actually
rules yeah I get laid all the time I
love having sex every weekend with a
different partner I'm trying to get my
body count to a thousand before I die
um marriage is stupid don't believe in
God anymore yeah yeah God isn't real
yeah
say I don't know man also what this
guy's describing is such a mental prison
yeah better yourself every day it's like
all right did your parents call you a
loser all the time like what why why
what's the motivation
you know that's he's just the next
iteration in the morning routine guy
yeah
that that archetype will never go away
yeah yeah which kind of rules yeah
morning routine guy used to be like he
used to I feel like it was mostly
oriented around like shaving and working
out
yeah there's a lot of morning routines
yeah and journaling yeah yeah journaling
and then you know
Sleek surfaces and and then I shave yeah
oh yeah you're saying in the very
beginning it was like dudes and Gillette
ads yeah yeah yeah but then like
YouTubers kind of came along and then
like they kind of continued that and
then added waking up early is probably
the first thing yeah yeah that's you
know like people wake up at 5 30 that's
[__] crazy now they're my choice yeah
yeah these guys are the first ones to
like do it by choice now morning routine
guy is like this [__] Space Marine
version where he's like I get up at four
and worship God for two hours and it's
so much [__] it's like cold plunge yeah
like eating the right you know no seed
oils
um so much [__] religion yeah so much
hidden one yeah you have to do so much
to be a morning routine guy yo now and
and you have to do it every day
it's like a militant [__] workout
yeah mentally physically you got to be
on dude yeah because then you have to
have an afternoon routine that's what an
evening routine I think that's the point
is like in a sleep routine it's gone
from morning routine to just regimen
yeah yeah routine guy yeah you're not
more it's it's not just [__] I'm a
poutine guy yeah
yeah
boudin's stuffed yeah bacon work chop
guy
I'm a poutine guy
I'm a morning routine guy
that's what I am I'd be poutine I mean
poutine this dick nice
nice in the toilet in the morning and
taking a piss
I piece I'm a morning peace sitting down
guy I did get a cold plunge though and I
set it up and I've started to use it
yeah and you like it and you do cold
yeah I mean I guess I'm a little bit of
a morning routine guy
when you start coming in here talking
about Jesus and [__] that's when I know
like fully [__] I'm like all right my
guy's a routine guy not just no it's
probably gonna happen God
who know I mean I already got the coal
Plunge at this point it's like a
snowball it's like AI you can't really
control it yeah yeah it is yeah you know
what I mean it's compounding yeah I've
been thinking about religion a lot
yeah dude yeah you set up uh Auto GPT
to give me a window into what my life
would be like a little bit more
religious
dude you becoming a god guy would be
crazy
we should just become girl defined and
replace them we should and complete the
meme yes
it's like what happened to the [__]
remember the you're the girl to find
video have you seen those guys now yeah
strip all this [__] we're like
secular music is bad
listening to music is a sin we regret
everything we've ever done
and we're here to use our platform to
start new
so did you hear about that crazy event
this weekend yeah there's gonna be tons
of hot chicks there yeah that's not our
definition of fun yeah sorry
our definition of fun is getting closer
to our creator
and grinder I mean praying yeah
Frank and grinder are pretty close it'll
be funny if people were like have you
seen the you know the girl to find dudes
have you seen them recently and then
have you seen the girl Define girls
recently and they you know added up
you know they're hanging out with sex ed
now right wait what what they're giving
sex head no because they're married so
it's like cool yeah to do it now yeah
but yeah anyway yeah yeah they're all
yet in yeah they're like hanging out
with that remember that chick in Toronto
what was her name we watched her videos
I think she was a fan of ours remember
she had a face tattoo yes
that girl legend yeah the legend sorry
yeah
yeah they're posted up with her yeah you
know what Sagittarius would come on our
side
she'd be all about God and [__] yeah
changed yeah I think the biggest thing
and look dude with the muscle tee and
[__] I know he's like trying to be
whatever positive role model
I just think what's really funny about
all of this with like young people
creating these like you know guides and
[__] this is like none of these
people know what they're gonna be even
in three to four years yeah
this dude might like try Molly huge yeah
she's massive oh my God yeah
you're gonna say you might try Molly I'm
gonna try Molly
holy [__] this is actually pretty sick
drugs are sweet
yeah he might go down some crazy path in
like three years he's like what happened
what's this guy's name
Timon
what happened to the creek what happened
to Timon
and it's like uh oh yeah he used to love
God but then um
yeah he got like caught up like selling
like pounds of mollies and I was doing a
15-year sentence
I mean he definitely does steroids so
yeah you think you don't think he just
might be Natty yeah I don't know Nadia
Natty Alpha
but I do think that giving advice like
this is not bad but like when you do it
in a way where it's like I'm better than
you yeah ashamed yeah for going to the
club yeah that's probably not the best
way to like resonate with people because
all the people that are liking that are
like people that are like yeah I don't
go to the club I'm better than yeah I'm
better than the people that do yeah
but instead if you're like here's how
much money going to the club is costing
you every weekend you probably spend
that money elsewhere people be like oh
yeah you're right yeah or like here's
how like bad alcohol is to drink every
single day or whatever the [__] you know
you know what's really funny is
picturing a dude like this like at a
party
giving all this like whatever and then
some dude walks in with like an open
t-shirt who's like half his weight and
he's like I have [__] Coke and I have
the party's like yo this guy rules yeah
he's like wait no no no this is cool I'm
like I don't I don't know I don't know
man this guy in the small jeans with the
small waist is kind of cool being high
sounds cool yeah
it's like successful people we can get
high with our creator yeah yeah yeah